isn't it fascinating how the simple act
of drawing a line on the map can
transform the way we see and experience
the world and how those spaces in
between lines borders become places they
become places where language and food
and music and people of different
cultures rub against each other in
beautiful and sometimes violent and
occasionally really ridiculous ways and
those lines drawn on a map can actually
create scars in the landscape and they
can create scars in our memories my
interest in borders came about when I
was searching for an architecture of the
borderlands and I was working on several
projects along the us-mexico border
designing buildings made out of mud
taken right from the ground and also
work on projects that you might say
immigrated to this landscape Prada Marfa
a land art sculpture that crosses the
border between art and architecture and
it demonstrated to me that architecture
could communicate ideas that were much
more politically and culturally complex
that architecture could be satirical and
serious at the same time and it could
speak to the disparities between wealth
and poverty and what's local and what's
foreign and so in my search for an
architecture of the borderlands I began
to wonder is the wall architecture I
began to document my thoughts and visits
to the wall by creating a series of
souvenirs to remind us of the time when
we built a wall and what a crazy idea
that was I created border games
postcards snow globes with little
architectural models inside of them and
maps that told the story of resilience
at the wall and sought for ways that
design
to bring to light the problems that the
border wall was creating so is the wall
architecture well it certainly is a
design structure and it's designed at a
research facility called fence lab where
they would load vehicles with ten
thousand pounds and Ram them into the
wall at 40 miles an hour to test the
walls and permeability but there was
also counter research going on on the
other side the design of portable draw
bridges that you can bring right up to
the wall and allow vehicles to drive
right over and like with all research
projects there are successes and there
are failures but it's this medieval
reactions to the wall draw bridges for
example that are because the wall itself
is an arcane medieval form of
architecture it's an overly simplistic
response to a complex set of issues and
a number of medieval technologies have
sprung up along the wall catapults that
launch bales of marijuana over the wall
or cannons that shoot packets of cocaine
and heroin over the wall now during
medieval times diseased dead bodies were
sometimes catapulted over walls as an
early form of biological warfare and
it's speculated that today humans are
being propelled over the wall as a form
of immigration a ridiculous idea but the
only person ever known to be documented
to have launched over the wall from
Mexico to the United States was in fact
a US citizen who was given permission to
human cannonball over the wall 200 feet
so long as he carried his passport in
hand and he landed safely in a net on
the other side and my thoughts are
inspired by a quote by the architect
Hassan Fathy who said architects do not
design walls but the spaces in between
so while I do not think that architects
should be designing walls I do think
it's important and urgent that they
should be at paying attention to those
spaces in between they should
be designing for the places and the
people the landscapes that the wall and
dangers now people already rising to
this occasion and while the purpose of
the wall is to keep people apart and
away it's actually bringing people
together in some really remarkable ways
holding social events like binational
yoga classes along the border to bring
people together across the divide I call
this the monument pose and have you ever
heard of wall-e ball
it's a borderland version of volleyball
and it's been played since 1979 along
the us-mexico border to celebrate by
national heritage and it raised some
interesting questions right it's such a
game even legal does hitting a ball back
and forth over the wall constitute
illegal trade the the beauty of
volleyball is that it transforms the
wall into nothing more than a line in
the sand negotiated by the minds and
body and spirits of players on both
sides and I think it's exactly these
kinds of two-sided negotiations that are
needed to bring down walls that divide
now throwing a ball over the wall is one
thing but throwing rocks over the wall
has caused damage to Border Patrol
vehicles and have injured Border Patrol
agents and the response from the US side
has been drastic Border Patrol agents
have fired through the wall killing
people throwing rocks on the Mexican
side and another response by Border
Patrol agents is direct baseball
backstops to protect themselves in their
vehicles and these backstops became a
permanent feature in the construction of
new walls and I began to wonder if like
volleyball
maybe baseball should be a permanent
feature at the border and walls could
start opening up allowing communities to
come across and play and if they hit a
home run maybe a Border Patrol agent
would just pick up the ball and throw it
back over to the other side
a Border Patrol agent Bozzio fast follow
a frozen treat from a vendor just a
couple feet away food and money is
exchanged to the wall entirely normal
event made illegal by that line drawn on
a map and a couple of millimeters of
steel and this scene reminded me of a
saying if you have more than you need
you should build longer tables and not
higher walls so I created this souvenir
to remember the moment that we could
share food and conversation across the
divide a swing allows one to enter and
swing over to the other side until
gravity Deportes them back to their own
country the border and the border wall
is thought of as a sort of political
theater today so perhaps we should
invite audiences to that theater to a
bi-national theatre where people can
come together with performers musicians
maybe the wall is nothing more than an
enormous instrument the world's largest
xylophone and we could play down this
wall with weapons of mass percussion
when I envisioned this by National
Library I wanted to imagine a space
where one could share books and
information and knowledge across the
divide where the wall was nothing more
than a bookshelf and perhaps the best
way to illustrate the mutual
relationship that we have with Mexico in
the United States is by imagining a
teeter-totter where the actions on one
side had a direct consequence on what
happens on the other side because you
see the border itself is both a symbolic
and literal fulcrum for us-mexico
relations and building walls between
neighbors severs those relationships
you've probably remember this quote good
fences make good neighbors it's often
thought of as the moral of Robert
Frost's poem ending walls but the poem
is really about questioning the need for
building walls at all it's really a poem
about mending human relationships my
favorite line is the first one something
there is that doesn't love a wall
because if there's one thing that's
clear to me there are not two sides
defined by a wall this is one landscape
divided on one side it might look like
this a man is mowing his lawn while the
wall is looming in his backyard and on
the other side it might look like this
the wall is the fourth wall of someone's
house but the reality is that the wall
is cutting through people's lives it is
cutting through our private property our
public lands our Native American lands
our cities a university our
neighborhoods and I couldn't help but
wonder what it would be like if the wall
cut through a house
remember those disparities between
wealth and poverty on the right is the
average size of a house in El Paso Texas
and on the left is the average size of a
house in Juarez and here the wall cuts
directly through the kitchen table and
here the wall cuts through the bed in
the bedroom because I wanted to
communicate how the wall is not only
dividing places it's dividing people
it's dividing families and the
unfortunate politics of the wall is
today is dividing children from their
parents you might be familiar with this
well-known traffic sign it was designed
by graphic designer John hood a Native
American War veteran working for the
California Department of Transportation
and he was tasked with creating a sign
to warn motorists of immigrants who were
stranded along side the highway and who
might attempt to run across the road
hood related the plight of the immigrant
today to that of the Navajo during the
long walk and this is really a brilliant
piece of design activism and he was very
careful in thinking about using a little
girl with pigtails for example because
he thought that's who motorists might
empathize with the most and he used the
silhouette of the civil rights leader
since our Chaves to create the head of
the Father I wanted to build upon the
brilliance of this sign to call
attention to the problem of child
separation at the border and I made one
very simple move
I turned the families to face each other
and in the last few weeks
had the opportunity to bring that sign
back to the highway to tell a story the
story of the relationships that we
should be mending and a reminder that we
should be designing a reunited States
and not a divided States
thank you
[Applause]